ABHISHEK KASHYAP: We just
launched BigQuery ML,
a new technology for machine
learning in BigQuery using SQL.
Now you may ask, so what?
To illustrate, let us
take a marketing analyst
at a retail company.
One of your projects,
a very typical project,
is to plan marketing
campaigns for website visitors
to drive them to come
back and purchase.
There are 1 million
website visitors a month,
of which less than 1%
come back and purchase.
You already know
that it's going to be
highly inefficient to
market to everyone.
What you need is a way to rank
the visitors and then market
only to the top ones.
How do you do that?
You need to build a
machine learning model
to rank these visitors.
You have the website data
from Google Analytics.
You have your sales database,
all in BigQuery already.
But how do you build this model?
You'll likely need a
data scientist and a way
to move this data out
of your data warehouse.
However, as is always
the case, your company
has a data science
team of 10, and they
are busy with other projects.
That is where
BigQuery ML comes in.
BigQuery ML enables
you to create a model
without having to move data,
or learning a new language,
or relying on capacity
from another team.
Let's see this in action.
You start by writing a
SQL query to select data
from the Google Analytics
table, which is illustrated here
through a public data set we
have for anyone to access.
And you are going to love this.
To do machine learning
on top, all you need
is two lines of SQL code--
CREATE MODEL and PREDICT.
That's it.
We'll CREATE MODEL,
give it a name.
Tell us it is a logistic
regression model,
and it's going to predict
if a visitor will buy later.
With that, click Run query.
The model is built, all
within BigQuery using SQL.
Once the model is ready, just
write another simple SQL query
that will predict, using the
model name that you have given,
and get the predictions
on new visitors.
From there, you can
build your BI reports
and take all marketing actions
you need to take on this code
visitor list.
Cool, right?
Now let's see how
this model did.
You will find that
re-marketing to just the top 6%
of the visitors provides a 9x
marketing ROI versus targeting
all visitors.
And what more?
You still reach 50% of
the potential buyers
after targeting just
6% of the visitors.
Now, that is an impressive
return with such little work.
And you can further optimize
this by planning campaigns
where you spend more on higher
scored leads and less on lower.
You may have noticed that
to get these results,
no help was needed from
a data science team,
and you did not have
to move data, either,
to build this machine
learning model.
All you did was to write
two lines of familiar SQL,
which you are an
expert at, and we
took care of everything
machine learning
to build this model for you.
That is how simple machine
learning is with BigQuery ML.
The technology was developed
by the Google Research team,
and we have brought it to
our BigQuery customers.
To learn more, visit
the BigQuery website
and start doing machine
learning yourself
with just two lines of SQL.
Thank you.
[JINGLE PLAYING]